and it's a great pleasure to introduce
sparrows who is a longtime colleague of
SIDS at Yale and a neighbor of mine in
Hamden so sparrows left Yale at Harvard
and then on to Biogen and he's famous
for discovering the notch signaling
pathway which is a very important
pathway which he discovered in fruit
flies that controls epithelial cells
differentiation and proliferation and
what we now know is that also controls
development in humans and it's
dysregulated in cancer and is being seen
as a target for cancer therapy so I
think it's a nice illustration how basic
research can lead in directions that
we're totally unpredictable in something
that we can continue to support and of
course it himself is intended to do that
he's bait based on news work on RNA SP
he's developing methods to regulate gene
expression and prevent or Treat human
diseases including malaria and influenza
so with that I'm happy nutritive spiros
oh Sid this is a picture of the Yale
bulletin when Sid was awarded the Nobel
Prize and I think that it's still
hanging on my desk since since then it
is still hanging on my desk so Sid a
monomer is it so this is hang on my desk
still listed and I just it's an honor
and a pleasure and this is the truth to
be here and thank you for almost what 35
years of friendship and science so I
could not come here which is home in
many ways without talking about not
rather than anything else both because I
can't say anything else about anything
else as well as as well as this is I
think appropriate that the area to do
that so my story at Yale started in 1980
when this Sur person Joe gall found me
in a Gordon conference and asked me
whether I would be interested in coming
at Yale this resulted in a job in
the view and in that interview actually
which was successful at least for me I
don't know if this turned out to be
successful for Yale but but and at the
audience actually I sit down to give my
job talk and I think fred sanger there
so I've done my PhD and he was visiting
Yale so fred was in front I've done my
PhD at the MRC where I first met August
people like Tom and Roger and actually I
remember mark Tasha who came for a few
months at the MRC to see that make sure
that maniatis was doing the right
experiments I suppose so and and I came
to Yale armed with a chromosome break
that was breaking into the North Shore
to the north locust thou not sir husband
was a gene that was first discovered in
1914 by Dexter in in Morgan's lab and it
was as you can see it has a little bit
of notches there this is happens in
haplin sufficient jail that's what it's
called not and the gene stained sort of
in limbo if you will only for a long
time but it became quite a star in
developmental genetics by this man
don't pull sir whose lab actually I took
over when I came to Yale they said a
picture that I took from dawn in 1985
and the remarkable thing about Don was
that he was probably the first person to
link genes with development now you most
of specialist younger people I will
never know that that genes were thought
in or the kind of genes that Morgan this
weird bunch of people that was around
Morgan that was telling were are were
relevant only for terminal traits like
the wing of the fly and so on and but
not for embryogenesis not for
morphogenesis so Don was the first
person actually to my knowledge to link
that this is his thesis
in Caltech Advisors Sturdevant and of
Jansky
and he actually says that there there's
no differentiation if you if you have
lots of function of not you lack the
differentiation of the ectoderm at the
expense of hypodermic structures so it
was this differential this kind of
switch so he did dawn deficiency mapping
and he had mapped a knot around the 3 c7
region of the X chromosome and Bidwell
Jones was the only land
that was working or not when I started
work on was one lab was doing fine
structure cytogenetics and he had mapped
three things I mean not not slow goes in
right at 3 c7 so we used chromosome
walking and jumping and a vogue mrs. lab
in in Stanford and to look to clone the
breakpoint and that was my my job that
was the the thing that I was going to
set up my lab 1 as I said not signaling
not the the phenotype of not was
becoming very important because if you
had lack of knowledge you would see a
switch in differentiation so things that
were supposed to become neuroblasts were
switching fate and becoming thermo
blasts so this kind of switch was was
something quite interesting obviously so
armed with the with a breakpoint we went
ahead and cloned the entire locus turned
out to be 2700 amino acid protein
transmembrane with 836 EGF repeats
outside I submitted the paper in on
Friday and Gould Benji Lewin called
Monday it's ours actually not not much
it was as one of the editorial people
and said you want this figure to be this
way or this way I couldn't believe it I
could not believe it
of course Benji lowing as usual he was
excited about the wrong thing he was
excited but he was excited which was I
was at the good end of the stick at this
point and he was excited about the EGF
repeats because the EGF repeats was the
first time that EGF was sort of linked
with with lower eukaryotes I mean if you
will so we but the important thing for
us was not that it was that it was a
transmembrane protein and that because
that implied the existence of a cell
interaction mechanism something on the
outside that the protein talks to and
something on the inside and that's so
that that's how my story sort of started
with with not not signaling turned out
to be one of the one of the seven or
eight or you want to plus or minus
pathways that govern essentially
embryonic morphogenesis that was mostly
through the work of the beautiful work
of yan in this line and and her
colleagues but but I think that you know
they're so not turned out to be a very
fundamental if you will pathway in for
embryonic morphogenesis everything flies
humans the Truvia nor otherwise are
governed by these by these rather simple
if you will
interaction it's signaling pathways so
the what is clear however is that that
not effects it's complex so it's
actually quite appropriate that I talk
after you because you talk about
specificity and I could save my talk
called pleiotropy if you will which is
in a sense the opposite is I'm familiar
with the Simon book it's a great great
book but I interpret it in a somewhat
different way to explain or rather to
justify apply atrophy which is the other
side of the coin in many ways anyway
multiple tissues are affected by notes
activity multiple developmental stages
and multiple developmental events and it
affects differentiation the effects
proliferation it affects movement
yeah and in effect apoptosis so all the
ingredients that are necessary to make
hello en to make a three-dimensional
structure may make it make an organism
so a few things how does it do it first
of all the development that logic of not
is in spite of its extraordinary
priority and I'll come back to that
again and again the development that
logic is run simple what notes does is
links the fate of one cell that
miraculously acquires it somehow to the
next-door neighbors that's what it does
no matter where we're in what species in
what that's what it does and and how
does it and that has profound
consequences in morphogenesis the first
one is that it is responsible for
lineage segregation so we have a sea of
cells that are similar or equivalent and
then one decides to become something and
the consequence of that decision is
saying to the other ones you become X or
you don't become anything or whatever
alright the second thing is one of the
pathways one of the pathways that
controls but borders both of these
events obviously quite important if you
build up a three-dimensional organism
well how does it do that
what is again the basic kind of logic
well it is that that not the notch
pathway is actually the absorption what
I do I did something so stupid
okay where's the pointer oh there it is
there it is there so it does it by by
essentially having a membrane-bound
receptor that talks to a membrane bound
ligand on the other side of the cell and
over the years we have been trying to
dissect the pathway as you will see not
very successfully as you will go on but
the the basic the basic elements of the
core pathway is you have a ligand on one
cell the ligand interacts physically and
we have characterized this biochemistry
of with a receptor and the consequence
of that is the cleavage the
intracellular domain which translocates
into the nucleus and then does his job
transcriptionally it it it associates
with a result with a with a repressor
with a activator and so on and it
controls not transcription one element
that I want to mention to you is that
essentially all of this pathway all of
the core was done here at the end I'm in
over the years I'm in over 17 years that
wasn't overnight again
so one aspect of notes that I want to
mention which i think is crucial in
terms of trying to give you an overview
of the of the pathway if you look at two
cells that are equivalent I told you
what happens is that if you look at the
receptor and the expression of the
receptor and the ligand they actually
very often are equivalent so you have
two things that's it's both the
expressed both the receptor and the
ligand and the question is you know what
is which cell will become the receiving
versus the the signaling cell absolutely
a crucial decision all right so so what
what's happening for reasons I mean you
have one cell that may have a small
difference between the ligand and the
receptor and then through a very
complicated as we will see feedback
loops and external
influences and so on eventually what
happens is the cell that ends up with
more ligand with more ligand becomes the
signaling cell the one that whereas with
more receptor it becomes the receiving
cell that of course implies right that
anything that will influence the number
of receptors and the number of ligands
on the surface is essentially
potentially a controlling mechanism for
not all right so all the trafficking
events that you can imagine could be
used theoretically either the the
receptor and the ligand traveling to the
to the to the surface how it is the
stability the ubiquity relation of how
you know how stable the protein is and
so on so so I think that what I will I
will do from now onwards is really tell
you how we have been trying to
deconvolute the complexity because the
the the core that I showed you which is
in textbooks is deceptively simple but
when I say deceptively it's deal with a
big you know capital capital D really
alright and this is work that covers
from 85 to 2016 which is a long time
even if you take into account stupidity
and incompetence you still have been you
know this is it even even with that it
is it is a complex problem alright so
let me go through some examples of the
to show you the complexity of the locus
alright again again at the end by 10 10
Xu who is a professor at of genetics in
here now was my graduate student he
found through a genetic genetic analysis
deltax which it turned out to be a with
gaze that associates with not ubiquity
ladies and as effects its stability all
right in trying to to look at the
circuitry that exists and Inter and and
controls not we found some late
years that courts which is the the fly
equivalent of the non-visual better
arresting associates with deltax and it
is this association that accelerates the
destruction of not so if you express
deltax and codes you destroy not very
fast okay and the consequence of that is
that you have these lots of function
phenotype which you are all familiar
with by now
alright yeah not just lots of function
alright now what happens if you look at
if you take this phenotype here which is
a double phenotype really it's a double
it's a it's expresses delta x and chords
and what happens a few asked the
question how can i influence that
phenotype how can i modulate that
phenotype the tool is genetic screens
mode you modifier screens and if you do
that what all before i say that well let
me make one more point yeah so if you
lost a function of of chords i told you
that gain a function of course if you
express course and delta x you
down-regulate not so if you do that you
can see actually in a mosaic here this
dark patch here is quartz - alright so
if you don't have quartz you up regulate
there the the protein you make more
protein here is that in spite of the
fact that you make much more protein
here if you look at the downstream
elements the transcriptional activity of
not the signaling of not using a marker
you can see that in this patch here only
only part of it not just activated so
the context dependence of activation is
just just make that remain make that at
that point so how complex is the
circuitry that that actually governs
these kinds of interactions again as I
said earlier genetic screens to look
asking the question if I mutate genes in
the genome or every gene in the genome
or 60% of the Jesus you know which is
the actual number and I combined it with
that do I see suppressors
enhancers and the answer is yes I can
see both suppressor so I'm making this
phenotype better and and and enhancer so
there are now the the kind of bad news
if you will is that if you look at how
many we got
there are hundreds and twenty hundred
forty of these things if you look at the
logic of what kind of proteins are
capable of modulating that phenotype
there's no rhyme and reason is
everything is there okay complexity
first-serve hint asking we have two
interrelated questions one by our
calculate the reason I say Mark Hackel
because the son of dark chemical words I
know if Doug is here Doug he's doing
very well still and and Greg here whose
it was a graduate student mark was a
postdoc and the question was you know
how complex is the circuitry now I told
you that if you if you down regulate not
you see this wing notice now if you if
you if you ask the question how many
genes are capable of actually modulating
that phenotype so interacting
genetically so we engineer something
that is lots of function not and then
ask the question how many genes can you
see I can modulate the phenotype
enhancing it or suppressing it just
genetic interactions and the answer was
ridiculous there's about 500 genes so 5%
of you know almost again sort of
complexity I should also say that each
one of those genes if you want to
analyze that it's one postdoc is the lab
of a poster all right so I just want to
tell you so how complex is the
integration of these of these pathways
so in this particular screen mark found
two new Interactive's if i vanmeer it
doesn't matter what they are it doesn't
matter at all and we knew from the
literature that Mir is interacting with
a kid skilled not sinter actors are
interacting with a kid skilled and and
these inter actors actually also
known to inhibit the Iroquois complex it
doesn't matter if you don't know what
I'm talking about it makes no difference
please yeah yes yes these are all
overexpress correct which all the
caveats that you can imagine so we know
that tgf-beta has been associated before
with Mir and and E 5 we know that mere 5
has been associated with with Hedgehog
and we know that Mir is also has been
interacting genetically with wingless so
you can see that the knots modulation
can be modulated if you will or is
actually associated with all of these
pathways which are the pathways that
control morphogenesis if you will if we
ask the question more directly you take
embryos you activate rats in two
different developmental stages and you
activate not simultaneously and
individually and so on and ask the
question how many what do I see in terms
of of genes that are upregulated or
downregulated only by simultaneous not
and rass activation and the answer is we
found 235 237 genes but the more
important finding is a that if you look
in this 237 genes you see members of the
wind pathway the the RTK nuclear
receptor not Jack's that Hedgehog
DPP again interaction between knots and
all these all these pathways one other
remarkable thing is that if you ask the
question that what happens with the rasa
ante and not 65% of the wrasse target
65% of wrasse targets are capable of
being modulated by not incredible sort
of you know interaction between between
these two pathways
now if not not all then not siglent has
been deeply associated with with
tumorigenesis and proliferation so we
wanted to find out first of all to see
whether or not we can actually look at
again these kinds of inter in the
integration of signaling via V tumors
and and I'll give you two examples of
that first one is I want to say that in
not has been directly implicated in in
pol Laveau blastic leukemias so if you
activate not you can actually cause TL
for blasting leukemias but it has been
also associated with a whole variety of
solid tumors not in a direct way and and
I'll tell you what I mean by that and
we'll talk about mammary glands and they
intestine so if you activate not using
mmtv in this particular case in a mouse
you can actually see almost with a
hundred percent penetrance this adenoma
that are being that are that are being
formed in in almost all mammary glands
ah sorry sorry but what do I mean sorry
sorry absolutely what do I mean by notes
activation you actually express the
intracellular domain I told you that
it's cleaved and it goes in so we just
expressed the intracellular domain the
signal that will trigger a transcription
that's what's activation okay so if you
look at if you express the intracellular
domain which is the in quadratic form by
the way into your leukemias and so on
you can actually see these these these
tumors but these tumors are not gonna
feed adenocarcinomas there are the nomas
that actually still can respond to the
normal apoptotic machinery that governs
in volusia but if on the other hand and
this and then you take and these are to
be these are pregnancy dependent tumors
and if you take them out the same mouse
this one here again and put it through
pregnancy again these tumors form
and again they regress but if you do it
a few times
eventually they don't regress and they
become bona fide adenocarcinomas and
this is an example this is the popular
reform which is the benign form let's
say and and you can see actually next to
it there is a there is a solid pattern
which is typical of of adenocarcinomas
so it is essentially the they not
activating not expressing the
intracellular domain will give you a
hyperplastic condition which then given
accumulates mutations that will make it
so it is essentially the activation plus
another mutation but will give you the
the oncogenic the orogenic phenotype
same thing is true in the in the gut in
the intestine this is if you if you
activate this is the wild type of the
intestine and these are the this is at
the crypts here if you activate not in
those crypts you can actually see that
you're gonna you stimulate proliferation
and we know looking mechanistically now
this this problem that this
proliferation
it depends or not on wing signaling so
if you if you inhibit wing signaling
then this is not proliferating anymore
all right now if you look at if you if
you take if you take a PC which is that
I don't know mitosis poor polyposis coli
that's why and in a heterozygous form in
humans that's what we don't call a loss
copies a heterozygous form will give you
this an enormous so if you take a mouse
and you make you make it heterozygote
what happens is that you essentially you
are getting about five lesions per
intestine at the enormous not
adenocarcinomas and if you look at the
kaplan-meier curve here if you activate
not nothing happens the proliferates but
nothing happens in terms of you get
tumors if you take a PC over plus the
heterozygote condition you get about
five lesions
if you add not activated not then
instead of five lesions you get hundred
and fifteen or hundred and twenty
lesions so you blow up them the the gut
with an enormous not the normal version
of us but that eventually of course
become adenocarcinoma and they and they
mice nice
so the oncogenic properties if you will
of not it's not so directly but it is
important cooperation is in coordination
with other things how can we look at
that in a bit more rational way
well flies again we can asked wouldn't
do a screen and ask the question does
can I get can identify genes that with
activated not will actually induce
proliferation simple question so to
speak so if you activate not in the eye
under the certain genetic conditions you
make an eye that is slightly bigger so
this is sensitized background now we
take this fly and we cross it with all
kinds of mutations in a genome-wide
fashion about sixty percent of the
genome that's the collection of flies we
have and you can actually see that we
can identify many things
here's whoops here is wingless again who
can identify many things that even Joel
Rosenbaum has no clue about Flies can
see that this is not normal I mean it's
a big it's a big thing I wouldn't you
know what that is anyway so but again
once again if we look at the numbers
that were getting that 200 modifiers
they some of them are actually quite
interesting a 37 of those that I'm
actually metastatic so you are have it
in the eye and then you can actually see
that every now and then you see eye
tissue in other parts of the body and it
looks as if it I mean if you do the
analysis that it is true metastases I
mean if you look now again what are
these genes all over the place
everything I mean no rhyme and reason
they are always in spite of the fact
that this overexpression and so on you
always get the right suspects I mean all
the rights aspects in terms of non
modulators of knots activity okay yeah I
mean it's it's it is a circular argument
yes I don't yes yes yes
so they if you look at all the there is
a Jing they you know the the screens
that I told you what you see is there is
app there is very little overlap really
all right now whether this is because it
is a James that you know this is
tissue-specific whether its father I
don't know but the fact is that this
core pathway that I showed you in the
beginning there are many many ways that
you can actually influence it so this is
not simplicity this is not specificity
this is huge pleiotropy is there any
hope in in in this well we in an attempt
to try and be kovala to at least some of
that what we have been doing is we have
tried to look at protein the protein the
what we wanted to do for better or for
worse is to look at protein interactions
defined complexes in proteins and then
try to connect this physical map with a
genetic map in an attempt to deconvolute
at least some of this complexity so what
we what we started to do a few years ago
was heroic and stupid maybe or mindless
and that is to take take genes take
proteins attack them express them in
cells bring down the complexes define
what did they interact with and then
sort of by automatically put everything
together
the first installment of this has been
published a couple of a few years ago in
flies and this is the so-called hairball
alright which I will describe to you in
excruciating detail in a second but the
and we are just about finished actually
doing the entire map which has about
10,000 proteins that we have tagged
expressed and did all this this work a
lot of work and and a lot of caveats but
this is a baseline we have checked a
number of things that I'll come to that
in a second and in parallel together
with with Wade Harper and Steve he my
colleagues at Harvard we're doing the
human proteome again this has this has I
said this is even worse this has also
now finished so we're putting all of
that stuff together and of course the
most interesting part and this is why is
to compare the two is to what degree
these are comparable all right yes about
10,000 yeah it's a lot of work but but
just to give you an example in terms of
not again going back to there if you
look at these the the complexes that I
showed you in the hairball the colors
are actually geo terms so these colors
are putting together proteins that have
been have similar functions within the
in terms of geo these are a few a few
complexes that contain modifiers from
any wise of the screens that I showed
you and we're looking at modifiers at
the complexes that have at least have a
50% enrichment so 50% of the proteins
have been associated genetically with
not many of these this was the first
time there were these associations were
made and if you ask the question that
how many of these how many of these of
the remaining proteins in a particular
complex that have never been associated
with not whether or not they interact
with not
the answer is yes that they do so there
is a good predictability of the map as
far as that as far of course the most
interesting part is starting now after
almost seven years of very very hard to
work and that is part of this this
hairball if you will and what we're
trying to do is look now at the dynamics
of that of that map so looking at
changing genetic context as well as drug
contests so if you take a cell and you
put in a particular drug in high
concentrations low concentrations and
look at now these relationships how they
change and if they change in in using
quantitative proteomics so revision
isobaric labeling and look at also at
the quantities of the of the relative
members this is something that that were
just started doing and yeah well we just
what what we are one one I'll tell you
what one second here so if you take one
particular complex there are two columns
with two questions that we're asking if
you disrupt members of that complex what
happens to the complex does it collapse
or not if it does collapse for example I
mean I'm just giving is what happens to
thee all to the next-door neighbors what
happens to the system because if you can
you find essentially nodes that will one
disrupt it you can actually drop the
system you can actually do that
biochemistry if you have a specific
question and we are doing that in
certain certain circumstances yes yeah
each of the ten thousand proteins it's
this is these are all overexpression
experiments all by doing the biology and
speak up with the question because I am
oh the question they the question is a
classic question and that is how do
these are overexpression experiments and
how do we know that these are relevant
essentially all right how do
know that this which is totally
reasonable question and it's only they
through the looking at the biology of
particular interactions that you can
actually see whether or not this is
relevant or not so if I have a complex
that has one target which is not let's
say alright and this interacts with four
other proteins you find no if I see that
this modifier of not is modified by
these proteins as well I suspect that
this is probably something real maybe
they're a titration experiment level
with expression versus connectivity no
that's what you need to do of that but
you know this is 10,000 proteins and and
seven years of work it start with one or
two at a time yeah one or two times
that's that's a given
now we've done that obviously right
otherwise you wouldn't have been able to
say anything and this is the baseline
yes now to what degree the or the
overexpression effects the overall map I
cannot tell you but I can tell you that
the only way that you can actually do
that I mean so you know except what you
just said which is impossible to do is
to look at particular complexes as
revealed by that map and as suggest as
this map suggests functionality between
a particular interaction and just look
at the biology there's no other way of
doing it and every time we've Sun we've
done that it has been actually proven to
be okay so so the the predictability of
the map I'm sure there are things there
that are not correct but the
predictability of the map is actually
quite astonishing yeah correct
absolutely absolutely and for us yeah
the the genetic interaction the
existence of a generally if if the map
says that a interacts with B if if that
n if we show functionally that interact
with B in vivo then that's good enough
they actually agree most of the time in
the case of knots where we have looked
at it yeah yeah well I can't believe
that doesn't matter I mean you know
especially with transcription factors
and so on
it's I mean if you overexpress something
you do get artifacts and no doubt about
it no doubt about it yeah so then base
map is in drosophila cell culture as is
the human one and there are different
strains for each protein that is run by
Gail four different strains of its rotor
what do you mean I mean for each protein
you want to test you have to have a
different construct for the gal for UAS
and so on a the protein interaction map
is done in a different way right I mean
you take them the protein you tag it and
you express it in in cells all right
yeah but you have to have how do you
express it in cells don't have you drive
your driver with golf or yeah but is it
an integrated you just get notoriously
smart so please please you know try and
are you adding perhaps you're adding a
no I mean these are this is so you get
one protein you express it I don't
express it on a vector on a virus yes
yes yeah
what you hope to come out of this in
terms of what I think that is biology
I'm sorry to say you know interactions I
mean you are we are going to learn about
how how complex the system is put
together what are they what ain't there
actually is what I mean the fact that
you have two things that are interacting
together because of a biochemical
experiment the question is in vivo how
this interaction is modulated but you
have to do a titration experiment for
all those interactions putative
interactions spills over here okay I
will bet I'm sorry go ahead all of all
the pathways signaling pathways
initially whether it's Hedgehog or when
are defects in those pathways result in
a defects and the way the system
differentiates seven figures instead of
five the tubule tubules and the mammary
glands don't branch correctly the bones
don't elongate properly or or get too
long or will be too short
so they result in problems in
differentiation those problems boil down
to tissues that are not developing
correctly for example the mammary gland
they're not making branches the kidney
they won't be forming proper proximal
and distal tubules those all are cell
cell interactions so finally my question
if you have and not is at the core of a
lot of these signaling pathways so if
you have two cells in the cell-cell
interaction is so important to get the
proper differentiation of a tube sheet
fingers and so forth when you have now
on the surface how does that cell tell
thee let's say the adjacent cell
I have not here interact with me with DX
or your receptor what is the signaling
between one cell to another because that
cell interaction initially is what's
going to determine the struck the proper
structure the initial interaction is a
physical interaction between the ligand
and the receptor on the surface how does
the receptor how does that cell say hey
how do you determine that cell has the
proper receptor on it you've got not
here it's going to react with another
cell with a receptor is there signaling
between the not containing cell and the
cell it's going to interact with its
surface to say okay will join yeah there
is a transcendence at OCS the ligand
touches the receptor the receptor is
cleaved and the extracellular part goes
into the receiving cell in the sending
cell and the intracellular part of the
of the notes expressing cell let's say
goes into the nucleus and starts
transcription there's a large literature
that's developing now on episomes
small vesicles that come out of one cell
and go to close my close close signaling
to an adjacent so we okay yeah we have a
loop that's not very interact with us
we've looked at that and we have no
evidence for that
I know I mean that's that's we we have
looked at this we have found no evidence
so far could I suggest a simple
experiment well no in that case okay
could I suggest a simple experiment with
with your resources poof we can do in
two weeks so the idea you can visit good
experiment it's a great experiment go
ahead unfortunately we'll go ahead let
me eat all this right okay so you can
easily
scan genomes to find out where all the
enhancers are okay you overexpress
knotch I guarantee you it's gonna make
all kinds of new enhancers you'll have
all kinds of nonspecific quote unquote
effects so then how can you trust the
results result exactly all your results
which are which are based on assuming
specificity where it's probably not
specific because it's over produced
he'll appear tropic pathway that effect
you have caught no no the pathway can
become pleiotropic so one of my first
nono by overexpression you just got all
you got in the cell well yeah but that's
hard I'm telling you very simply but
anyway all you've got all these pathways
have the same thing right kinase is and
blah blah and they can talk to each
other and you know it's what happens in
cancer you over produce somebody and it
works on a different pathway that
doesn't mean though that those are real
quote-unquote ordinary interactions
doesn't solve any biological problem
except that you the output we're
measuring is about logical at was right
so the question is how can you influence
that biological output and whether or
not this biological output can be
modulated by what okay so you can
actually say that you have one element
that can influence that but if there are
a hundred elements then how do they do
that I interpret Mark's results
oppositely the mark that you're saying
that the specificity doesn't matter very
much so you get three amino acids and
it's gonna turn this on no no I mean in
a way yes but these weak interactions
for example when you activate in
bacteria off DNA they're extremely weak
on DNA and you get you know what is
activation is just a chemist wouldn't
notice there's a factor of ten or a
hundred okay so what he's saying no no
no but if you overexpress
for example an activator you do over
existence
fundamental point all right and that is
that if you overexpress it is an
artificial if you will experiment but if
this artificial experiment gives you
answers that are relevant then and the
relevant there those are really relevant
but the relevant answer is a biology you
know it's not the biochemistry I'm
afraid relevant is a consequence in in a
in an in a biological output that's
what's relevant is for definition
question is how you test that biological
outcome what